we're here at Hatton Garden where last  night there was a robbery in the vault  it's the biggest robbery in British  criminal history  they were extremely professional and  highly organized outfit  okay hey what if he's opposed the first  job I got arrested for I'm searching the  Hatton Garden is a niche could never  scratch gasps rats in Brian will be dead  tomorrow if I can round up the right  people here's some young bloke see it  wasn't as officer we're not capable so  disappointed when people stooped to bake  semi I think they don't know what  they've got the burn leaving the dish  ran like the wind you tell a single soul  about this and I'll cut your balls off  nice bloke  you